tacones, perlas y sus típicos sombreros de ala ancha.
De un momento a otro, se supone que empezarán a hablar
de la porcelana fina de sus respectivas abuelas.
Pero no.
En cambio, las oímos decir,
"Miren.
Debe haber algo muerto por aquí".
Alzamos la vista y sobre la izquierda vemos buitres que vuelan en círculo.
En ese momento, se me ocurrió
que si esas mujeres, en ese evento hípico, relacionaron los buitres con la muerte,
entonces ¿por qué no tenemos más en cuenta a estas aves
en una escena del crimen?
Es bien sabido que los buitres están relacionados con la muerte,
pero no se entiende bien cómo.
Por ejemplo, veamos este correo electrónico
que me envió un detective en Lousiana:
"Lauren, ha habido un secuestro.
¿Qué águilas ratoneras o buitres hay en Lousiana?"
Antes de hablar del secuestro,
me referiré primero a esta pregunta que me hacen todo el tiempo
sobre ambas aves.
Las águilas ratoneras no viven en EE.UU.
Son águilas que viven en Europa.
Esas grandes aves negras que vemos volando en círculo en EE.UU.
son buitres.
En Lousiana, hay dos tipos de buitres:
el buitre pavo y el buitre negro.
Para entender cabalmente el papel de los buitres en la ciencia forense,
les presentaré este caso.
A través de este correo electrónico, algunas cosas quedaban claras.
Damos por hecho que, para el detective, el sujeto está muerto
y que quiere usar a los buitres para encontrar el cadáver.
Al igual que las señoras de Nashville,
el detective cree que los buitres que vuelan en círculos
lo conducirán hasta el cuerpo.
No es tan sencillo.
No sé si alguna vez han visto un buitre de cerca
o si han pasado un tiempo con ellos,
pero son inmensos, realmente.
Su envergadura supera 1,80 m.
Los buitres vuelan en círculo
porque son demasiado grandes para batir las alas y volar,
y por eso planean.
Planean en columnas termales, que son remolinos o pequeños tornados
producidos por diferencias de presión en el aire
y se forman durante el día cuando el sol calienta el suelo.
Por eso, cuando vemos a un buitre volando en círculo,
en realidad está yendo del punto A al B,
y no sobrevolando un cadáver.
Por cierto, si queremos usar un buitre para encontrar un cuerpo,
busquémoslo más bien posado en un árbol o en un poste.
Los buitres son demasiado grandes y lentos para cazar,
por eso están obligados a buscar carroña.
De hecho, son los únicos animales del mundo
que dependen de la muerte para subsistir.
El buitre pavo que aquí vemos es maravilloso,
pues es una de las pocas aves con sentido del olfato.
Va directo al cadáver cuando percibe la sustancia química
que ese cuerpo libera al descomponerse.
El rol de estas aves ha ido evolucionando
para limpiar la Tierra de las toxinas que producen los cadáveres.
Una vez que ha detectado el cuerpo,
el buitre pavo desciende y de inmediato se lanza a carroñear.
Primero quitan los ojos,
luego desgarran la piel,
arrancan los tejidos y dejan el esqueleto.
En definitiva, la importancia de los buitres no está arriba,
sino en el suelo.
La conducta carroñera de los buitres es algo macabra.
Si alguna vez tienen una mala experiencia en una primera cita,
hablen de esta charla
y seguramente no habrá una segunda llamada del potencial pretendiente.
(Risas)
A pesar de esa truculencia, los buitres son actores forenses clave,
y les diré por qué.
Los buitres consumen un cadáver humano
de la misma manera que lo hacen con un animal muerto.
Pero nunca nos enteramos de esto,
y es porque estas aves son muy buenas en lo suyo.
Si los buitres dependen de la muerte para sobrevivir y si consumen humanos,
entonces ¿cómo es posible que no figuren en los libros forenses
ni en los manuales de capacitación?
¿La respuesta?
Tradicionalmente, los investigadores han excluido a los animales carroñeros
de los estudios de descomposición
aislando en una jaula el material en estado de putrefacción.
¿Por qué?
Porque los investigadores temían que esos animales se llevaran ese material
y ellos quedaran sin datos que informar.
En consecuencia, excluir esos animales
deriva en un largo proceso de esqueletización,
que es la información que usan los detectives actualmente
en sus investigaciones.
Cuando vemos el esqueleto de un cuerpo en la escena del crimen,
pensamos, "Vaya, quién sabe cuánto tiempo lleva esto aquí".
No, no, no, no, no.
Los buitres aceleran la descomposición.
Y ese esqueleto podría haber estado allí
no más de cinco días si fue presa de los buitres.
El no tener en cuenta la participación de los buitres
puede llevar a los expertos forenses a hacer una estimación errónea
sobre el tiempo de muerte de la víctima
y, como resultado, buscar la identidad equivocada de la persona desaparecida.
Por lo tanto, los forenses deberían tomar en cuenta
las pruebas dejadas por los buitres
y debería aplicarse una ley que contemple la participación de estas aves
y la posibilidad de una muerte reciente cuando se encuentran restos de esqueleto.
Volvamos al caso de secuestro.
Respondí a los detectives
y les dije que los buitres son afectos a las zonas donde hay agua
y donde habita el ciervo de cola blanca.
Suelen aparecer dentro de los cinco días posteriores a la muerte
y dejarán la columna vertebral intacta...
y algunas plumas.
Los detectives me responden:
"Encontramos el cuerpo enterrado en una fosa poco profunda.
También encontramos las plumas que Ud. mencionó".
Pero, aparentemente, había un problema:
las plumas estaban a unos 36 m del lugar donde se halló el cuerpo.
Esas plumas estaban al lado de un cono de pino ensangrentado.
La sangre no atrae a los buitres y estos no suelen deambular.
Pueden hacerlo hasta 12 m, pero no 36 m.
Sería un desperdicio de energía
para un ave que no sabe cuándo encontrará su próxima comida.
Mi primera tarea, en este caso,
fue determinar si los buitres estuvieron en el lugar.
Efectivamente, la pluma cercana al cono de pino
era compatible con la de un buitre pavo.
¿Por qué, entonces, un buitre se apartaría 36 metros?
Lo que me fascina de los buitres es que su comportamiento
puede explicarse desde la biología y la física.
Empecé a recordar los muchos ejercicios de adiestramiento
que hice con estas aves en una granja de cuerpos en Texas.
Una granja de cuerpos es un lugar donde uno puede donar su cuerpo a la ciencia.
También recordé mis prácticas en las que atrapaba
y marcaba a los buitres con un GPS.
Y luego fue el proceso de un año de monitoreo de las aves
mediante la tecnología de localización a distancia.
Después de consultar mis anotaciones de campo, lo comprendí de pronto.
Había dos cosas que alejarían a un buitre 36 m del cadáver:
vísceras y materia encefálica.
Presenté esta información a los detectives
y supe que, según ellos sospechaban, la víctima había sido incapacitada
por un fuerte traumatismo de cráneo.
Se especulaba que el golpe había ocurrido en el lugar donde estaba el cono de pino
y que la víctima fue arrastrada 36 m y enterrada en una fosa poco profunda.
Esto sugería que la materia cerebral fue lo que atrajo al buitre
y demuestra que el comportamiento de los buitres puede ayudar
a reunir parte de la evidencia.
Los detectives también me enviaron esta foto.
El brazo de la víctima asoma fuera de la fosa.
Como especialistas forenses, debemos considerar la escena completa.
La pluma hallada al lado del cono de pino
indicaba que los buitres estuvieron en el lugar.
Esta foto también describe
el comportamiento carroñero característico de los buitres.
Si nos acercamos, vemos un plumón blanco,
típico del buitre pavo.
También se observa que la piel cerca de la muñeca ha sido desgarrada.
El buitre pavo siente el olor del cuerpo putrefacto y baja a tierra.
Escarba entre las agujas de pino,
saca la mano del cuerpo hacia afuera,
desgarra la piel con el pico
y empieza a separar los tejidos blandos del hueso.
La secuencia es desgarrar y arrancar, desgarrar y arrancar.
Esta foto muestra la eficiencia de los buitres en su práctica carroñera.
Esto es muy importante porque puede ayudar a los detectives
a reconstruir la línea temporal de esa muerte.
No es que la evidencia sea abrumadora.
No es que nos encontraremos con los buitres en la escena del crimen.
Pero dejan pistas muy sutiles.
En lugar de buscar al buitre,
hay que buscar plumas y huesos intactos.
Los buitres son importantes
porque son muy buenos y muy rápidos en lo suyo.
Son como tornados:
si parpadeamos, los perdemos de vista.
Le di al detective mi opinión sobre la evidencia dejada por los buitres,
y él presentó esa evidencia en la corte.
El secuestro que mencioné fue un caso de pena de muerte.
Y el acusado fue declarado culpable.
Este caso demuestra que estudiar el comportamiento de los buitres
puede introducir innovaciones en la ciencia forense.
Una persona asesinada
merece la investigación más completa posible.
La inclusión de los buitres en los estudios forenses
puede brindar una idea más exacta de lo que ocurrió, cuándo y a quién.
Por eso, la próxima vez que estén en la escena del crimen
junto a un cadáver...
(Risas)
Busquen las pistas dejadas por los buitres en el suelo.
Y si alguien les habla de buitres en una cita,
tengan por seguro que es el cuidador.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)